et chers collègues je vous propose que
nous démarrions la commission nous avons
fini pour ceux qui étaient là à 3h30 ce
matin la séance et le président Cambon
va nous rejoindre en cours de réunion il
m'a demandé de d'ouvrir et que nous
démarrions notre réunion et nous
recevons donc ce matin Monsieur Thomas
gomard directeur de l'Institut français
des relations internationales et
Monsieur Bruno terre très directeur
adjoint de la Fondation pour la
Recherche stratégie messieurs je vous
remercie de vous être rendu disponible
dans des circonstances aussi un peu
particulière pour venir participer dans
ce format de table ronde et nous livrer
votre analyse sur les enjeux de la
prochaine LPM vous êtes tous deux
déminant géopolitologue et experts des
relations internationales la guerre en
Ukraine bouleverse depuis plus d'un an
la conception que les Français et les
Européens pouvaient se faire de la
guerre ne s'agit plus d'intervention
militaire choisie sur des théâtres
extérieurs et face à un adversaire
asymétrique mais bien d'un champ de
bataille au cœur de l'Europe où
s'affrontent indirectement les grandes
puissances ce gommard dans votre dernier
ouvrage les ambitions inavouées vous
analysez les antagonistes et les
ambitions des principales puissances
partenaires et adversaires de la France
et déplorer cette formule si vous
permettez je vous cite de désinvolture
géopolitique dont les Européens ont fait
preuve en ignorant les confrontations
que prépare les Américains les Russes et
les Chinois
donc vos précédents ouvrages notamment
l'affolement du monde vous annonciers
déjà 3 théâtres régionaux de
confrontation de puissance susceptibles
de déclencher une déflagration mondiale
l'Ukraine Taïwan et l'Iran la France est
donc bien à l'heure des choix qui n'est
plus celui d'un conflit de haute
incendie de haute intensité hypothétique
mais bien celui d'un engagement majeur à
quelques heures nos frontières qu'elles
sont pour vous dans ce contexte les
enjeux de la LPM à venir d'où dont nous
ne connaissons bien sûr pas encore les
détails
l'affrontement massif des forces
conventionnelles remet en lumière les
insuffisances que de nombreux experts et
parlementaires relayés quant à l'absence
de masse et de profondeur de nos forces
quant à la relégation de la préparation
opérationnelle des stocks de munitions
j'en mémoire un rapport de la rente
Corporation qui salue les capacités
techniques des armées françaises sur
tout le spectre du champ de bataille
mais sans la capacité de durer votre
analyse nous sera précieuse je n'oublie
pas la spécificité maintenant unique de
notre pays au sein de l'Union européenne
qui est d'être une nation membres du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies de
thé de la dissuasion nucléaire à cet
égard Monsieur Bruno tertre et vous avez
publié plusieurs ouvrages sur les
questions nu et en est un expert reconnu
à l'heure où les grandes masses
budgétaires de la prochaine LPM sont en
cours de finalisation comment répartir
ces quatre en 413 milliards d'euros
annoncés une chose semble acquise la
continuité de notre dissuasion il
s'agira d'ailleurs d'un effort encore
plus conséquent de la nation puisque le
développement de plusieurs vecteurs des
deux composantes
océaniques et aériennes de la dissuasion
et programmée d'ici 15 ans nous devrions
voir la troisième génération de
sous-marin nucléaires lanceurs d'engins
SNL 3G et le futur missile hypersonique
airsol nucléaire
ASN 4G successeur de l'AS MPa actuel la
dissuasion est une charge que la France
supporte avec toujours le risque d'un
effet d'éviction au détriment de
l'équipement de nos forces
conventionnelles problèmes que n'ont pas
nos partenaires européens qui ne que
participer à la dissuasion américaine au
sein de l'OTAN ainsi Monsieur tertre
dans un article récent vous avez posé la
question de la cohérence sans
l'abondance de la nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire selon vous
quelles sont les principaux arbitrages à
trancher pouvons-nous tout assumer de
front masse et technologies théâtre
Centre Europe Afrique Moyen-Orient et
Indo-Pacifique cyber et expace
exo-atmosphérique cette liste de
questions est évidemment pas exhaustive
mes collègues la complèteront le moment
venu à l'issue de vos exposés linéaires
et vous l'avez compris dans l'attente du
texte nous souhaitons pouvoir réfléchir
avec vous sur le contexte c'est-à-dire
ce qui constitue selon vous l'état des
menaces notre capacité à y faire face et
nos besoins je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo et qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et sur les réseaux
sociaux et ce que je vous passe la
parole en commençant peut-être par vous
monsieur gomard si vous le voulez bien
merci monsieur le Président pour votre
invitation et pour cette introduction
déjà très très complète mesdames
messieurs et sénateurs c'est toujours un
honneur de pouvoir
participer et contribuer à vos travaux
et donc je le ferai aujourd'hui avec un
exposé luminaire d'une 10 15 minutes
d'après ce qu'on a ce qu'on m'a indiqué
nous ne sommes pas coordonnées avec
Bruno mais nous avons l'habitude de à la
fois je pense savoir ce qu'il va dire et
puis je pense qu'il sait ce que je vais
dire
nous avons aussi des points de débat
donc ça permettra aussi peut-être de
nourrir voilà mon propre départ je vais
commencer avec
trois remarques liminaires et puis
ensuite j'articule ré mon propos en
trois volets assez synthétiques
première remarque c'est que nous sommes
avec cette discussion autour de la LPM
et l'attente évidemment du test j'entre
pas sur les aspects de calendrier que
vous connaissez mieux que moi mais nous
sommes à mon sens face à une situation
très paradoxale et ce paradoxe est
difficile à expliquer à nos concitoyens
le président de la République de mon
point de vue se distingue très
clairement de ces quatre prédécesseurs
en ayant augmenté la dépense militaire
lors de son
mandat précédent et en voulant continuer
à le faire et pourtant la LPM qui se
dessine donne une impression au mieux de
pouvoir se maintenir au niveau qui était
le nôtre précédemment
et ce paradoxe qui est très difficile à
expliquer politiquement compte tenu des
contraintes budgétaires qui s'exercent
dans tous les dans tous les domaines
rappels une évidence historique
malheureusement oublier par les
mandatures précédentes c'est que on ne
rattrape jamais en période de crise sur
quelques années des décennies de
désarmement et c'est la situation au
fond dans laquelle nous sommes et
l'ensemble à mon sens des forces
politiques ou des milieux d'expertise
sont désormais concernés par cet état de
fait
deuxième remarque introductive c'est
d'essayer de dire quelques mots sur le
cadre intellectuel d'analyse stratégique
qui nous occupent quotidiennement Bruno
et moi dans lequel s'inscrit cette LPM
et là aussi les frappements de constater
le décalage entre les sommes en jeu
absolument considérables l'effort
demandé à la nation et l'effort
analytique pour le concevoir et le
justifier juste pour prendre une image
on peut se remémorer les livres blancs
de jadis et se remémorer les 52 pages de
la revue nationale stratégique présentée
en novembre dernier qui oriente notre
réflexion
cette revue nationale
stratégique n'est ni une tentative de
grande stratégie à impliquant toutes les
composantes nécessaires à une réflexion
sur une ou deux générations et en
particulier la composante énergique
climat ni une stratégie de défense
puisque elle aborde un certain nombre de
sujets de manière assez fragmenté
elle a le mérite d'exister et c'est en
quelque sorte le cadre qui est le nôtre
pour essayer
de préparer au mieux cette loi de
programmation militaire la RNS ça
appelle je le rappelle pour citer
l'avant-propos de prendre la République
à une mobilisation plus intégrale pour
mieux nous armer à tous égards face aux
défis historique d'un monde où la
compétition et la confrontation se
confondent
donc troisième point d'introduction ce
que je vous propose dans mon exposé
c'est au fond de rappeler que l'analyse
stratégique n'a pas de sens si on la
conçoit comme une photographie à un
moment T mais elle ne prend son sens que
comme un processus continue ininterrompu
comme un fil qui se déroule et je vous
propose donc de dérouler le fil au fond
qui nous sépare de novembre 2022 à mars
2023 pour essayer
d'orienter la préparation de la loi de
programmation militaire dans la
meilleure direction
alors le premier volet
quelle lecture on peut extérieure
peut-on avoir des débats en cours autour
de la de la LPM trois points le premier
c'est un rappel historique pour préparer
cette audition je me suis replongé dans
les livres d'un de mes maîtres Robert
Franck qui avait consacré sa thèse en
1982 au prix du rarement français entre
1935 et 1939 donc sous le Front
populaire c'était ce qui était réédité
en 2017 je vais pas vous je vais pas
tout rappeler parce que nous n'avons pas
le temps et c'est pas le propos mais je
retiens deux points qui à mon avis
doivent être gardés à l'esprit au regard
aussi de cette notion d'économie de
guerre dont le président le président a
utilisé en juin dernier
le réarmment massif décidé par le Front
Populaire a été
un échec industriel
en raison d'une incapacité collective à
augmenter la production des armements
premier appel historique deuxième rappel
historique de Robert Frank c'est le
décalage qui existe toujours entre un
réarmement matériel et un réarmement
moral avec un retard pour la deuxième
partie dans la prise de conscience des
dangers extérieurs
je pense que c'est deux rappels
historiques gardent une pertinence au
regard du contexte actuel
le deuxième point ce sont les trois
critiques que j'ai déjà formulées
publiquement à l'égard de la
de la LBM telle qu'elle nous a été
présenté la première c'est peut-être un
point de désaccord avec
Bruno terretre qui a insisté
effectivement sur l'importance de la
cohérence et de la réactivité comme les
deux maîtres mots dans l'article
monsieur le Président que vous
mentionniez en introduction
comme lui je comprends parfaitement la
logique intellectuelle derrière ces deux
termes de cohérence et de réactivité
mais je pense qu'il masse
l'absence sinon d'endurance du moins de
semis endurance sur un certain nombre de
cas de figure très préoccupants au fond
tout se passe comme si cette guerre
d'Ukraine devait se finir rapidement ce
qui ne sera pas le cas et tout se passe
aussi comme si
ça tombe d'engagement indépendamment de
l'article 5 dans le cadre de l'OTAN un
certain d'engagement que nous avons pris
pouvaient être traité sans un minimum de
semi endurance je pense pas à des
accords de sécurité que nous pouvons
avoir avec des pays comme les Émirats ou
comme la Grèce par exemple sans même
évoquer la situation de dromcom donc le
premier point de critique c'est qu'à mon
avis la notion d'endurance doit sous une
forme ou une autre être remise dans le
débat
la deuxième critique c'est que cette
notion d'économie de guerre
annoncée par le président de la
République encore une fois en juin
dernier ne correspond pas à la manière
dont les choses sont ressenties à la
fois par les industriels et plus
largement par nos citoyens même si
évidemment nous sommes dans une
situation économique très difficile
compte tenu de l'inflation
la loi de programmation militaire
insiste sur la nécessité de je cite un
maître sous tension la BITD la base
antique sexuelle de technologie et de
défense pour au fond l'encourager à
produire plus moins cher
cette mise sous tension est à certains
égards très compréhensibles mais elle ne
prend elle n'a pas de sens de mon point
de vue si elle n'est pas accompagnée
d'une mise sous tension du secteur
bancaire censé la financer on ne peut
pas penser l'un sans l'autre
troisième point de de critique c'est que
nous avons pris l'habitude
collectivement de nous présenter comme
la première année armée d'Europe et je
pense que c'est un trompe l'oeil très
dangereux
un trompe l'oeil à la fois vis-à-vis de
nos propres concitoyens et également un
trompe l'oeil vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires
cette reprogrammation militaire doit
aussi permettre de fédérer des efforts
européens je note d'ailleurs que dans le
montant supplémentaire qui était loué il
se rapprochera on verra au final mais
elle sera de l'ordre de 100 milliards ce
qui rappelle l'effort produit par
l'Allemagne et c'est évidemment pas un
hasard or de mon point de vue si la
France et l'Allemagne conserve une
centralité évidente au sein de l'Union
européenne en raison de leur poids
économique je pense que la France et
l'Allemagne sont en train aussi de payer
un coût politique pour la lecture qu'ils
ont eu du de la menace russe et de la
manière dont nous sommes arrivés à la
gare d'Ukraine dans sa deuxième phase de
février 2022
j'ai pris l'habitude de dire que Paris
et Berlin ont eu raison avec Moscou en
2003 contre l'intervention
anglo-américaine en Irak mais Paris et
Berlin ont été moins lucides que Londres
et Varsovie sur la réalité de la menace
russe et cela depuis un certain nombre
d'années
troisième
point les enseignements politiques ou
militaires que à mon avis nous devrions
essayer tous de tirer collectivement
dans le cas de cette préparation la loi
de programmation militaire le premier
c'est évidemment la guerre du crâne nous
comprenons le raisonnement consistant à
dire nous nous retrouverons jamais dans
une situation comme l'Ukraine puisque
nous sommes une puissance dotée et je
pense que c'est un raisonnement qui fait
l'impasse sur des situations
intermédiaires tout à fait envisageables
qui peuvent nous mettre dans des
situations stratégiques très délicates
et notamment vis-à-vis d'un certain
nombre de nos alliés de l'OTAN
idem je pense qu'il y a une sorte de
voile jetée sur l'expérience les
expériences et les enseignements
politiques aux militaires attirés de
notre engagement seul
nous n'avons pas fini avec le terrorisme
djihadiste de mon point de vue ni avec
la déstabilisation de cette de cette de
cette région et plus largement de la
situation dans un certain nombre de pays
africains
le deuxième volet de cette présentation
c'est effectivement sur un dans un dans
une perspective davantage géopolitique
de repartir monsieur le Président des
des trois théâtres que vous avez évoqués
dans votre introduction parce que je
pense que la très grande difficulté qui
est la nôtre c'est la c'est de penser la
simultanéité et les effets de bord qui
existent entre ces trois théâtres
c'est-à-dire l'Ukraine
l'Iran mais j'ajouterai je vais faire un
cours développement là-dessus Israël et
la situation en mer de Chine
en ce qui concerne l'Ukraine on pourrait
revenir probablement plus en détail dans
dans la discussion mais désormais de
manière tout à fait claire la Russie a
deux ennemis
affiché et présenter comme tel
premier ennemi c'est la nation
ukrainienne il s'agit d'asservir
et le deuxième ennemi c'est l'Occident
collectif pour reprendre la formule
utilisée par le président Poutine
l'Ukraine à mon sens doit se lire comme
une guerre d'entraînement et ils ne sont
parfaitement illusoire de croire qu'un
arrangement territorial pourrait mettre
fin au dessin néo-impériaux de Vladimir
Poutine
le sujet et la pression vont s'exercer
très fortement dans les semaines qui
viennent à la fois sur la Moldavie et
sur la Géorgie qui est dans une
situation extrêmement délicate comme
vous le savez probablement parallèlement
on notera toujours une volonté à mon
avis de la part de la Russie de tester
la solidité de l'article 5 ou de se
livrer
à des stratégies indirectes par
l'intermédiaire de ses proxy c'est
évidemment aussi un des enseignements à
tirer de notre présence sociale comment
se fait-il que nous n'avons pas vu nous
n'avons pas voulu analyser à ce point la
main russe derrière Wagner
au Mali notamment
en arrière-plan la grande question très
difficile sur laquelle nous aurons
probablement un débat c'est quel est le
degré de convergence
entre la Chine la Russie et l'Iran
deuxième théâtre l'Iran pas besoin de
développer sur l'accélération de son
programme nucléaire sur la vigueur de la
répression contre la société civile
iranienne et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
envisager anticiper l'Iran sans être
extrêmement attentif aux évolutions
également en Israël
et à la trajectoire politique prise par
Israël actuellement
qui est au fond en train de verser dans
une forme délibéralisme avec là aussi
des manifestations et septembre de
contre-pouvoirs évidemment très
important mais cette évolution à mon
avis est une partie importante à
souligner et probablement un des points
nouveaux par rapport à novembre 2022
les deux questions sous-jacentes à
laquelle nous devons réfléchir c'est
quel serait l'attitude des Européens en
cas d'intervention
d'Israël en Iran
et quel serait l'attitude des Européens
en cas d'annexion partielle de la 6
Jordanie
troisième théâtre
Taïwan
là aussi on pourra on pourrait revenir
peut-être plus précisément il y a deux
données qui à mon avis ne sont pas
encore intégrés par
la majorité de nos concitoyens mais qui
que nous devons avoir
toujours en tête compte tenu de
l'évolution du triangle entre les
États-Unis et la Chine et l'Union
européenne au début des années 90
l'économie européenne était supérieure à
l'économie européenne ce n'est plus le
cas
et deuxième
fait très important la Chine en 2021 est
devenue le premier partenaire économique
de l'Union européenne et à vis-à-vis de
l'Union européenne une attitude tout à
fait différente de celle de la Russie
troisième et dernier volet la LPM comme
au fond outil
mise en scène ou pardon mise en œuvre
plutôt que mise en scène mise en œuvre
de ce concept de puissance d'équilibre
avec un S qui est présenté dans la revue
nationale stratégique
concept qui pour ma part ne me semble
absolument pas pertinent pour une raison
assez simple c'est que l'heure à mon
sens n'est pas du tout à trouver à
chercher une position de surplomb mais
bien plutôt essayer de se préparer au
plus vite et le moins mal possible au
choc que nous allons subir
et que de ce point de vue là la question
que nous devons nous poser c'est
qu'avons nous fait du temps stratégique
que les ucréiens nous ont offert depuis
un an
le deuxième point c'est
l'élargissement des fonctions
stratégiques dans la dans l'arns
évidemment pas parler à côté de Bruno de
la dissuasion on lui en parler de
manière beaucoup plus précise mais il y
a deux évolutions à mon sens à noter
pour la première
fonction la fonction de connaissance
compréhension et anticipation
je fais un rapide point un peu personnel
je pense que c'est une question tout à
fait importante pour les centres de
recherche que nous représentons à cette
table c'est fait-on confiance encore à
un effort de recherche sur le terrain et
ma réponse malheureusement est plutôt
d'être assez préoccupé par l'attention
qui est portée aux travaux que nous
pouvons produire
et la sixième fonction nouvelle qui est
cette fonction d'influence laquelle
comme vous le savez suscite un certain
nombre de débats
troisième point à mon avis cette loi de
programmation militaire devrait nous
encourager collectivement à revenir à un
certain nombre de classiques et ne pas
ceux écrit en son temps par le général
bof qui nous rappelle que la stratégie
est avant tout un exercice psychologique
et de ce point de vue là je pense que
nous avons deux questions à nous poser
qui veut ton convaincre
et de quoi et je suis aujourd'hui avec
cette notion de puissance d'équilibre un
peu en peine pour répondre à ces deux
questions
un mode conclusion pour dire que il me
semble et c'est aussi pour ça que je
suis très heureux de pouvoir participer
à votre travaux absolument indispensable
compte tenu de la gravité de la
situation d'une part et des sommes
enjeux d'autre part
d'élargir le débat sur ces questions de
défense et d'y associer le plus grand
nombre de concitoyens je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci Monsieur gomard pour vos propos
monsieur tertre merci monsieur le
Président je me joins bien sûr à mon
collègue amis Thomas pour vous remercier
de votre présence surtout après une nuit
très courte pour certains d'entre vous
nous sommes d'autant plus honorés
ayant eu la chance d'être associé
parfois de très loin et parfois de tout
près à la plupart des exercices de
réflexion stratégique et d'élaboration
des lois de programmation militaires
depuis plus de 25 ans maintenant il me
semble pour commencer qu'il y a toujours
trois pièges à éviter le premier c'est
de considérer que le monde est par
nature plus dangereux plus imprévisible
et plus instable qui ne l'était il y a 5
ou 6 ans maman de la préparation de la
précédente
loi de programmation militaire
là-dessus je vais citer
quelqu'un qui aussi a des maîtres pour
Thomas j'imagine rémoison tout
simplement qui nous invite toujours à
nous méfier de ce qu'il appelait
l'illusion rétrospective de la stabilité
on a toujours le sentiment qu'il y a 5
ans qu'il y a 10 ans qu'il y a 30 ans
que la guerre froide était plus stable
c'était plus prévisible c'était je
rappelle les certains d'entre vous le
savent bien que ce n'est pas du tout le
sentiment qu'on avait à l'époque pendant
la guerre froide donc je crois que c'est
toujours un premier point à rappeler
parce que cela nous conduit
naturellement cette erreur à mon sens à
tomber dans un deuxième piège qui lui
dit il faut faire toujours plus et que
les fameux 2% ne suffisent évidemment
pas et là je suis méfiant vis-à-vis de
cette notion un double égard d'abord
parce que je déteste le critère de 2% je
pense qu'il n'a aucun sens
pour de multiples raisons sur lesquelles
on pourrait revenir mais je suis sûr je
sais d'ailleurs que certains d'entre
vous ont déjà travaillé et ensuite parce
que aujourd'hui
ensemble difficile à nos concitoyens
d'accepter beaucoup plus que ce qui est
aujourd'hui envisagé par nos autorités
politiques la notion d'acceptabilité
sociale de sociétal de l'effort de
défense dans le contexte que nous se
connaissons doit être mesuré à l'aune de
ce que nous voulons avoir comme esprit
de défense et l'esprit défense au sens
le plus large du terme et donc je me
méfie énormément je ne suis pas connu
comme étant un ennemi des armées mais je
me méfie énormément du toujours plus
dans
dans ce domaine le troisième piège il
est évident et je crois que nous dit-on
grand pas mais c'est de préparer la
guerre d'aujourd'hui et pas celle de
demain piège pour le moins classique ce
qui me permet d'ouvrir ma courte
présentation qui sera je pense très
complémentaire à celle de Thomas sur la
question des conséquences de la guerre
d'Ukraine
naturellement
parler de conséquences ça veut dire
qu'on se projette déjà dans l'après nous
ne savons pas quand sera après et
j'ajouterai et là je pense que Thomas et
moi seront enfin nous ne savons même pas
s'il y aura un après se projeter dans
l'après et signifie et c'est bien c'est
bien humain que nous pouvons déjà
envisager dans six mois dans deux ans
qu'il y a un après je ne suis pas sûr du
tout que cela pourrait être le cas
thoba hésiter à se lancer sur les
questions de dissuasion j'hésite devant
lui à me lancer sur les la question
russe mais le scénario d'une Russie en
état de guerre permanente pour très
longtemps ce qui satisfait le pouvoir
actuel si tenté que Monsieur Poutine il
reste mais même s'il ne restait pas le
scénario dans lequel comme le disait
Thomas la Russie préparerait ses guerres
d'après c'est un scénario qui nous
empêche une certaine manière de nous
projeter après après l'Ukraine dans le
meilleur des cas pour nous nous aurions
une Russie affaiblie militairement mais
même une Russie affaiblie serait d'abord
une Russie encore Revanchiste et donc
encore un problème stratégique pour
l'Europe même si elle n'était pas une
menace militaire immédiate
et par ailleurs c'est une aussi qui à
l'évidence comme elle l'a toujours fait
et c'est bien naturel entre guillemets
en tout cas c'est le sens de l'histoire
pour les grandes buts pourquoi les
grandes puissances chercheraient à
reconstituer son potentiel militaire
classique si tenté qu'il ait été
véritablement affaibli au bout de
quelques années pour l'Europe cela
signifie et c'est là que je crois qu'il
faut se méfier de faire des parallèles
que l'on peut faire un peu rapidement
avec ce qui arrive aujourd'hui à
l'Ukraine nous avons une véritable
translation à l'est de la défense
collective de l'Europe qui n'est pas
terminée et puisque après-demain la
défense de l'Europe se fera sur le don
et pas sur le Rhin et nous n'aurons pas
à envisager une menace militaire à deux
étapes du tourne en France mais je n'ai
pas fait le calcul il faudra quelqu'un
le fasse à 5 ou 6 étapes ce qui fait
tout de même une grande différence et
c'est là que je crois que dire que nous
ne sommes pas menacés par une situation
alukrainienne et probablement vrai mais
à mon avis ça
je vais d'abord et avant tout pour des
raisons géographiques plus que par notre
possession que certains présentent comme
un totem de de la force nucléaire
française
l'Amérique Thomas on a parlé je voudrais
peut-être en dire un mot il y a sur la
présence américaine et sa garantie à
l'Europe ce que j'appelle trois trois
récits le récit premier récit René le
récit français l'Amérique s'en va oui
bah l'Amérique elle est toujours là ça
fait 70 ans que nous disons que
l'Amérique s'en va qu'elle va forcément
s'en aller elle est toujours là elle
revient même elle revient même
rappelez-vous que sous la présidence de
Barack Obama ce pivot vers l'Asie
annoncé par la Maison Blanche faisait
dire un nombre de responsables français
parfois parmi les plus éminents et les
plus brillants ça y est l'Amérique est
va partir vers l'Asie ça y est on était
en 2010
2011 le deuxième récit erroné c'est le
pendant c'est le récit allemand qui
consiste à dire sera toujours là
d'ailleurs elle est revenue évidemment
cet excès de confiance a été quelque peu
érodée par la présidence Trump mais
l'Allemagne a une capacité aussi à
trouver les moyens de se rassurer auprès
de Washington qui à mon avis parfois qui
dénote parfois un excès de confiance le
troisième récit René je l'appelle le
récit polonais qui consiste à dire du
moment qu'on a des forces américaines
chez nous concrètement une présence
réelle de réassurance mais aussi de
chèvres piquet comme on disait autant de
la guerre froide et bien on est
tranquille malheureusement il ne
faudrait qu'un tweet il ne faudrait
qu'un tweet au prochain président
américain pour
quasiment faire disparaître du point de
vue de sa crédibilité l'engagement
américain à défendre l'Europe soldat
américain en Pologne ou pas
bien sûr nous avons ce premier problème
le problème de janvier 2025 nous ne
pouvons pas du tout partir du principe
que le prochain président souhaitera
maintenir les réflexes transatlantiques
qui ont été ceux de l'administration
Biden
nous avons un deuxième problème qui est
le risque d'une crise soudaine en Asie
la plupart des spécialistes de la Chine
et de Taïwan estime qu'il est encore
improbable d'imaginer que Pékin veuille
se saisir de Taipei par la force dans
les années immédiates dans les deux
trois prochaines années je crois qu'il
serait à l'inverse imprudent pour nous
européen de parier sur l'absence de
surprise de la part de la Chine dans ce
domaine dans dans les on va dire au
moins dans les 5 ans
pour la France
je crois pour la France qui encore une
fois n'est pas menacé de disparition et
encore moins d'asservissement comme
comme les Ukraine aujourd'hui je crois
que le choix fondamental pour nous c'est
quel équilibre entre l'OTAN dans lequel
nous souhaitons être un allié exemplaire
je cite la revue nationale stratégique
et le reste de nos engagements et de nos
intérêts il était en temps de faire une
sorte de retour vers l'Est je crois que
ce choix en gros il consiste à tenir son
rang ou tenir un créneau
tenir un créneau vous souvenez sans
doute des débats de la guerre froide
c'était l'éternel débat devons-nous être
à l'avant à l'arrière avec une force de
réaction rapide quelle doit être la
portée de notre engagement avant un
éventuel conflit avec le Pacte de
Varsovie j'allais dire qu'aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière ce dilemme est
encore plus tranché puisque si nous
voulons continuer à persuader nos
alliés européens de l'importance de
notre engagement et de la nécessité
d'aller davantage vers l'autonomie
stratégique de l'Europe nous le savons
depuis longtemps il faut faire donner
des preuves d'amour envers l'OTAN c'est
comme ça donc il y a deux choses il y a
notre intérêt bien sûr d'alliance et
puis à notre intérêt aussi d'Européens
et de crédibilité notre engagement
européen je crois que le choix qui se
dessine tel que en tout cas on a pu le
voir dans les grandes lignes de
l'intervention présidentielle et qui
donc annonce peut-on supposer le projet
de loi de programmation militaire le
choix qui a été fait ça a été dire de
voilà s'il faut choisir entre déployer
une division aéro terrestre bien musclée
et très tout à fait prête à participer
dès les premiers jours non seulement à
réassurer rassurer pardon rassurance
c'est un thème un petit peu un petit peu
américain non seulement rassurer mais
aussi être prêt d'emblée à participer de
manière significative à la défense des
frontières de l'Union européenne et bien
c'était une première option possible ça
n'est pas l'option retenue et je suis
suffisamment critique envers la position
envers la politique française dans un
certain nombre de domaines pour être
très à l'aise lorsque je dis que le
choix qui semble l'orientation générale
qui semble devoir être donnée au projet
de loi de la programmation militaire me
semble être un choix sage et raisonnable
difficile message et ça pour plusieurs
raisons plus pour moi 5 raisons la
première je l'ai dit nous ne sommes pas
en première ligne c'est une évidence
mais la géographie compte encore nous
sommes pas dans le premier lit face à ce
qui restera la menace militaire russe
pour l'Europe deuxièmement encore je
vais être rapide puisque Thomas l'a déjà
a déjà commencé à l'énoncer nous avons
d'autres responsabilités et des
responsabilités spécifiques à la France
nos autres responsabilités elles ne sont
pas seulement propres à la France mais
le Moyen-Orient dans avec des accords de
défense là pour le coup qui est une
spécificité française les trois accords
de défense dont l'un que l'on dit
particulièrement contraignant avec les
Émirats arabes unis Thomas rappelé le
contexte particulièrement volatile
actuellement dans cette région du monde
l'Afrique bien sûr la Grèce avec lequel
Thomas l'a rappelé nous avons un accord
de défense particulier l'Afrique l'Indo
pacifique et l'outre-mer c'est
responsabilités d'abord certaines
d'entre elles nous ne pouvons pas les
abandonner puisque c'est le territoire
national
de zone économique exclusive à l'avenir
la Chine est évidemment pas une menace
militaire directe pour la France son
attention d'étendre sa domination dans
le Pacifique
occidental et toutefois chaque jour plus
avéré le développement des marines
centuryrières dans la région vous le
savez sera sera un défi pour nous n'y
attendons pas vu qu'il y a quelques mois
de deux bâtiments militaires iraniens
traverser la zone économique exclusive
de la Polynésie c'est c'est un signal de
c'est plutôt quelque chose qui annonce
d'autres types de manifestations des
puissances émergentes le renforcement
qualitatif de nos forces dites de
souveraineté qui se traduit qui devrait
se traduire notamment par la mise en
service de nouveaux patrouilleurs
outre-mer moderne et à mon sens fait par
fait partie à mon sens des urgences
difficilement contestable
j'ajoute c'est vrai que on le dit
beaucoup à Paris mais c'est une c'est un
point intéressant que la consolidation
de le principe au partenariat dans la
zone à l'eau Pacifique la ce qu'on
appelle la diagonale du Rafale avec les
Émirats arabes unis l'un des l'Indonésie
contribuera à mon sens à soit une
politique française indépendante dans la
région ça c'était le deuxième argument
nos autres responsabilités dont
certaines absolument incontournables la
troisième raison de ne pas tout miser
sur le retour à l'est c'est que je crois
que nous avons d'autres moyens de
montrer que nous pouvons être un allié
exemplaire dans l'OTAN les initiatives
que nous prenons je pense notamment à la
consolidation d'un élément sur le flanc
sud-est de de l'ayant Atlantique notre
effort de défense est bien sûr
la dissuasion nucléaire font partie des
des points sur lequel nous devons
insister lorsque on
cherche à démontrer montrer que nous
sommes effectivement un allié exemplaire
un point un point à ce sujet
l'exemplarité ça ne se décrète pas il y
a cette phrase justement dans la revue
de stratégie qui est défense de novembre
2022 qui m'a un petit peu laissé
perplexe la France est un allié
exemplaire non c'est c'est l'exemple
réalité c'est comme c'est comme la
beauté pour Oscar Wilde c'est dans les
yeux de c'est dans les yeux de l'autre
donc c'est la France se veut un allié
exemplaire mais décrétons pas
l'exemplarité je pense personnellement
que oui la France est un allié
exemplaire dans le temps je pense que
c'est vrai mais c'est pas à nous de le
décréter quatrième argument
la dissuasion le renouvellement de nos
moyens de dissuasion Thomas a commencé à
en dire un mot vous le savez on va avoir
une bosse budgétaire significative dans
les années qui viennent avec notamment
mais pas seulement la construction des
quatre sous-marins nucléaires dans
l'ensemble de nouvelles
le président de la République
a décidé d'après la presse il y a un an
de mettre trois SMS à la mer
simultanément ça n'avait pas été fait
depuis 40 ans je dis d'après la presse
que ce n'est pas une confirmation
officielle mais comme vous le savez il
n'y a pas eu non plus de déni vous
4L le c'est pas seulement pour pouvoir
en mettre 3 même si la mise sous tension
du système est incontestablement un
signal extrêmement important et le type
de signal que nous sommes les seuls avec
les Américains à pouvoir faire notre
grand partenaire nucléaire britannique
est à mon sens totalement incapable de
le faire mais surtout garantir vous le
savez je vais pas insisté sur ce point
vous avez déjà débattu de ce sujet si on
veut garantir un ou deux et c'est le en
permanence à la mer ce qui est dans le
contexte actuel me semble plutôt
raisonnable le format de 4 est
incontournable sur l'effet d'éviction je
suis un petit peu plus mesuré que qu'on
veut le dire parfois monsieur le
Président je crois que l'idée
consistance à dire le nucléaire crée
mécaniquement un effet de fiction sur
les autres grands équipements
conventionnels est une idée qui à
l'expérience je trouve n'est pas
forcément démontré puisque elle ne prend
pas en compte les bénéfices indirects
que là encore vous connaissez bien de la
dissuasion pour un ensemble de grands de
grands de grandes plateformes et de
grands équipements sur le plan
qualitatif également on connaît les
effets indirects de de la dissuasion
nucléaire et puisque
j'ai eu la chance de participer à
certains exercices dans lesquels on
discutait de manière très précise de ces
formats des différents formats des
grandes plateformes pour pour vous
donner par exemple au format
la question du nombre de sous-marins
nucléaires d'attaques dont nous
disposons il en faut x% en termes de
présence et de disponibilité pour la
dissuasion si on supprimait la
dissuasion demain je peux vous dire que
il
alors on peut débattre à l'envie des
notions de cohérence de réactivité
versus le volume et l'endurance
on va pas ici en tout cas je n'ai pas
forcément les moyens de disserter sur
notre capacité effective d'entrée dans
une économie de guerre à de produire x
tonnes de munitions par an c'est vrai
que nous avons appris parmi les nombreux
enseignements de la guerre d'Ukraine que
l'émulition c'est pas seulement pour
nous et là pour le coup il faut aussi
réfléchir je crois quand on parle de
haute intensité et de volume et de stock
de munitions non seulement à ce que nous
pourrions de voir consommer dans un
conflit même s'il n'est pas du même type
que celui qui consiste à repousser une
invasion massive de la part d'un pays
comme la Russie mais ce que nous
pourrions avoir aussi à proposer à
d'autres partenaires et plutôt alliés à
d'autres allées partenaires et alliés à
l'avenir dans d'autres conflits il y a
un sujet et un type de conflit en tout
cas un scénario une hypothèse
stratégique qu'on a thomas et moi assez
peu développés aujourd'hui elle est
sensible je crois que Thomas y a fait
allusion de manière indirecte c'est
l'idée d'un d'une crise majeure nous
opposons à un de nos alliés en
Méditerranée orientale j'ai parlé de
notre accord de défense avec la Grèce je
crois qu'encore une fois nous le prenons
au sérieux mais il faut savoir je crois
que vous le vous le savez bien
d'ailleurs que c'est un scénario qui
nous séparerait aussi de nombre de nos
alliés y compris les plus proches en
tout cas c'est un scénario très propre à
la France ça ne veut pas dire que la
France serait seul à défendre la Grèce
si son territoire souverain était
effectivement menacée mais en tout cas
ça serait probablement une crise
politique majeure au sein de de
l'Alliance atlantique en conclusion
monsieur le Président je pense que le
pari qui semble devoir être fait par le
par l'exécutif aujourd'hui est un pari
plutôt raisonnable qui exigera de notre
part de montrer que nous sommes nous
pouvons être un allié exemplaire même
sans un gros volume de force avec des
disponibilités opérationnelles très
importantes pour la défense immédiate
des frontières de l'Europe et je
terminerai puisque vous êtes le
président vice-président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense je terminerai en disant que
lorsqu'on a l'ambition d'être une
puissance d'équilibre avec un S comme
Thomas l'a rappelé que les moyens de la
diplomatie sont au moins aussi
importants que ceux de la défense et que
je fais partie de ceux qui regrettent
que trop longtemps même si les choses
s'améliorent un petit peu la diplomatie
était le parent pauvre dans dans les
équilibres budgétaires des des dernières
années alors que le levier en termes de
co-efficacité quand on veut être plus
sens d'équilibre ou au moins puissances
initiative la diplomatie reste notre
premier et meilleur levier merci
monsieur le président
merci à vous deux pour ces exposés très
claires et très intéressant alors j'ai
plusieurs collègues qui souhaitent poser
des questions ce que je vous propose
c'est de prendre les questions et puis
ensuite
vous reprendrez la parole pour les
réponses première prise de parole c'est
Hélène que nous Mouret
merci monsieur le Président merci
infiniment pour pour vous exposer moi je
vais commencer par exprimer deux regrets
non pas sur ce que vous venez de dire
mais sur le travail que nous effectuons
ici au Sénat nous avions voté en 2018 on
a LPM une clause de revoyure en 2021
c'est le signe n'a pas été respecté et
vous avez très justement rappeler la
nécessité d'une analyse en continu donc
est-ce que vous pensez que finalement
une telle clause devrait figurer dans la
prochaine
également nous n'avons pas participé
activement à la revue stratégique on
nous l'a présenté un soir au ministère
avec
deux jours je crois pour pouvoir donner
notre avis sur sur l'ensemble du texte
mais quand on parle de résilience d'un
peuple d'endurance de monter en
puissance des efforts de défense est-ce
que cela ne demande pas un engagement de
chacun et donc est-ce que aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas besoin d'un nouveau
livre blanc donc c'est ma deuxième
question
sur le la défense européenne nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur sur ce sujet je
pense que la guerre en Ukraine a mis en
évidence en effet nos faiblesses mais la
lumière du réarmement polonais notre
propre réarmement ne semble-t-il pas
limité en terme de masse qu'elle regarde
portez-vous sur le choix des Polonais
mais pas seulement eux ils ne sont pas
les seuls à acheter sur étagère
simplement ils le font massivement
puisque ce sont plusieurs centaines de
chars au musée de lance-roquette
aujourd'hui qui sont achetées à la Corée
donc quid de l'habilité de et de
s'inventer en puissance et quelle place
aujourd'hui pour la France dans l'Europe
dont vous avez très justement montré que
en fait le centre se déplace vers l'est
et dans son rapport aussi avec la montée
en puissance de puissance régionale
telle la Turquie par exemple
voilà et simplement un tout petit point
pour monsieur gomard vous avez parlé de
l'Ukraine et de l'Occident qui sont pour
la Russie des menaces mais est-ce que
vous considérez que ne considérez-vous
pas que la Chine en fait est une
véritable menace pour pour ce pays
pour la Russie
merci Hélène André Vallini maintenant
merci monsieur le Président oui une
remarque et puis une question de
remarque à la suite de ce qu'a dit
Monsieur tertre et je ne connais
virement pas le sujet aussi précisément
que lui mais il me semble quand même que
lorsque vous dites que le narratif du
retrait américain a été René
vous y allez un peu fort parce que moi
je me souviens des déclarations de Obama
confiant et par Trump qui qui laissait
vraiment entendre qu'il voulait se
retirer de l'Europe certes le narratif a
changé parce que la guerre en Ukraine a
éclaté que les États-Unis sont de retour
entre guillemets verbalement mais ils
avaient bien envisagé malgré tout de ce
de pivoter vers l'Asie me semble-t-il et
puis la question c'est pour monsieur
gomard vous avez dit tout à l'heure par
afrasant Barbara que le temps perdu ne
se rattrape jamais et moi j'ai une
question et je vais sortir un peu du
sujet d'aujourd'hui j'ai une question
qui me taraude depuis toujours sur le
rarement de l'Allemagne de 33 à 39
comment vous expliquer que l'Allemagne
puisse réarmer à ce point en six ans
je sais que c'est une question
historique qui n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec le débat sur l'actualité
militaire mais c'est quand même une
question intéressante qui qui fait écho
est-ce que vous avez dit l'Allemagne a
prouvé qu'on pouvait se remettre très
rapidement me semble-t-il
merci André Joël guerriot
merci président
aujourd'hui avec la guerre en Ukraine la
plupart des Européens considèrent qu'en
fait que la sécurité de notre continent
ne peut se penser s'organiser finalement
que dans le cadre de l'OTAN
parallèlement à ça on nous avons une
retraite
de troupes enfin de nos soldats dans le
continent africain
l'esplaner l'idée d'un échec et
affaiblissent de position sur le plan
international alors moi les questions
que j'aurais c'est de nature d'une part
si nous sommes pas capables de tenir la
Méditerranée où on voit qu'aujourd'hui
la situation est particulièrement
complexe avec beaucoup de conflits sur
la Méditerranée est-ce qu'on peut être
crédible lorsqu'on s'oriente vers des
ambitions sur la dopacifique et d'autre
part si nous avions avoir une priorité
pour faire que la France retrouve toute
sa crédibilité qu'elle serait elle merci
merci Joël landregatelin oui merci
monsieur le Président tout d'abord pour
vous dire que je bois du petit lait on
vous entendant parce que je me rappelle
il y a deux ans quand j'évoquais la
possibilité d'une simultané simultanéité
de crise
Ukraine Taïwan et errant on m'a beaucoup
ri au nez d'autant que l'Iran ça date
pas d'hier quand on lit les robux
d'affaires étrangères ou autres
stratégiques américaine c'était
omniprésent on a découvert la question
on a redécouvert la question de l'Iran
vraiment très récemment par rapport à
certains événements qui se sont tenus
c'est une chose mais surtout ma question
je voudrais reprendre quelque chose et
vous demander une précision monsieur
gomard vous avez évoqué l'importance des
moyens qui est mis dans la LPM et
l'intérêt moins important allez on va
dire à la réflexion stratégique qui est
à l'environnement moi je parle
franchement de désarmement intellectuel
de l'État c'est-à-dire quand je vois les
bien que nous consacrons véritablement à
la recherche stratégique diplomatique
compris je suis toujours étonné que de
voir certains ministères qui font appel
qui achètent des études du Germain
marshalf von ou de l'Atlantique Council
que c'est fintech à 800 personnes alors
que excusez-moi de le dire et eugar ou
un très grand travail que vous faites
vous êtes un peu réduit aux acquies dans
la matière et je pense que c'est très
difficile à mettre en oeuvre et puis un
autre élément et donc je voudrais vous
dire d'une certaine manière vous n'étiez
pas entendu mais je pense aussi il y a
un vrai manque de travail de réflexion
au long cours comme vous l'avez dit
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour Monsieur
Poutine c'est pas l'Ukraine au-delà de
la mer Noire c'est la mer Méditerranée
orientale tous les enjeux de
déstabilisation et il va falloir un
moment qu'on pense plus large qu'on
essaie de comprendre que tous les pions
qui ont été mis par la Fédération
domicile par Monsieur Poutine en Syrie
rie en Libye mais aussi à Chypre et pas
mal d'autres endroits plus l'Afrique ça
constitue un tout et quelque part ça
ressemble à un encerclement de
l'Occident en tous les cas l'Occident
européen moi je le dis comme ça et je
trouve que on est encore dans une
lecture le nez dans le guidon
merci André Olivier Cadic c'est monsieur
le Président oui deux questions une
relative à la résilience cyber et
l'autre à la guerre d'informationnelle
la résilience cyber a été érigée en
objective stratégique par la revue
nationale stratégique elle présente la
République a annoncé dans son discours
sur la LPM son souhait de voir doubler
notre capacité de traitement des
attaques cybers majeures on se demande
d'ailleurs si le seul objectif de
doublement de capacité est suffisant
quand on sait la progression
exponentielle des menaces répertoriées
par l'ansy et cyber malveillance au-delà
de ces chiffres comment véritablement
inscrire dans la prochaine LPM la
nécessité de rapprocher les fonctions
défensives et offensives
traditionnellement structurellement
séparés dans notre organisation actuelle
pour que la défense de nos intérêts
civils et militaires soient mieux
assurés concernant la guerre
informationnelle on était avec le
général Murray à l'instant qui
s'occupait de nos forces de sécurité au
Qatar pendant la Coupe du Monde et
bien seul endroit où en fait les
autorités Cathary ont été débordées
c'est justement la guerre
informationnelle qui leur a été faite
pendant la Coupe du monde à l'échelle de
la LPM la création de vigime peut
sembler une réponse encore modeste pour
mettre en œuvre la fonction stratégique
qui a été définie par la revue nationale
stratégique d'ailleurs c'est au mystère
des Affaires étrangères que cette
fonction a été confiée pour ce qui
concerne notre influence extérieure je
dois dire que par exemple Taïwan qui à
mon avis le plus performant dans ce
domaine c'est pas du tout le choix
qu'ils ont fait ces réponses
institutionnelles se situent d'ailleurs
en marge de la LPM en tant que tel alors
même que l'on peut dire que notre trait
militaire du Mali et du Burkina Faso
sont des défaites sur le champ de la
bataille de l'influence quelle analyse
vous suggère ce constat et qu'elle
répondent pouvez-vous suggérer
merci Olivier la liste de questions
ayant doublé je vais vous proposer de
faire deux séries donc je donne la
parole à Joël guerriot-mellam pour sa
question et je vous laisserai une
dizaine de minutes de réponses et on
fera une deuxième série oui merci
beaucoup et pardon d'avoir est en retard
mais journée du 8 mars oblige j'avais un
petit déjeuner de travail avec la
première ministre sur ces questions donc
désolé pour ça désolé de pas vous avoir
entendu monsieur gomard et je suis en
temps arrivée juste au moment où
Monsieur tartré parlé de ces 2% et d'une
manière assez négative donc j'aimerais
l'interroger là-dessus puisque pour moi
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
pertinent je rappelle que c'est une
dimension qui a été
choisie par un Français général
Paloméros qui était le commandant
suprême autant pour la transformation et
je trouve que c'est vraiment très
pertinent parce que je le vois au sein
de l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN
et vis-à-vis des pays alliés parce que
c'est vraiment un encouragement et un
élément qui permet aux états de se
mesurer et de progresser et on a vu les
progrès très importants qui ont été
réalisés avec bien sûr
3,8% pour la graisse de virgule 4 pour
la Pologne et on sent l'impact donc
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi cette analyse
monsieur tertrey ça me paraît important
et deuxièmement en termes de guerre de
sur la désinformation qui est
extrêmement importante là aussi c'est un
souci au sein de l'OTAN moi je suis
catastrophe fait de voir à quel point
les fake news sont en train de se
diffuser partout en Europe et je trouve
et j'avais interrogé d'ailleurs le
secrétariat général de l'OTAN à ce sujet
il y a un manque de coordination alors
la réponse est de dire à mes c'est à
chaque état de travailler
parce que nous ne voulons pas nous
ingérer dans la pratique des états ça me
paraît une erreur au niveau français
est-ce que justement une fondation comme
les free des fines ne pourraient pas
mieux vous aider à contrer cette
désinformation parce que très
honnêtement je suis effaré de voir des
mensonges absolument énormes qui
circulent sur Twitter et sans quasiment
qu'une réponse merci
merci Joël je sais pas lequel des deux
vaut commencer
une dizaine de minutes 12 minutes à vous
deux bien sûr répondre aux autres
collègues
vos interventions et vos questions
étaient très riches donc je vais être
obligé d'être assez rapide
Madame le Ministre oui la clause de
revoyure c'est une évidence surtout
quand on a des LPM à 6 ans donc voilà
insister sur sur la clause de leur
royaume pour moi c'est une évidence
absolue la revue stratégique bien vous
savez les parlementaires n'ont pas été
les seuls à être exclus puisque les
personnalités individuelles et même les
signes tanks ont été exclus également de
ça rédaction alors c'est pas pour
prêcher pour notre chapelle mais là
encore je vais et je vais pas non plus
raconter mes guerres intellectuels mais
franchement la première commission du
Livre blanc par sa diversité par sa
représentativité était un formidable
exercice de fertilisation intellectuelle
et politique croisée vraiment j'en ai un
excellent souvenir alors qui veut pas
dire qu'il faille absolument un livre
blanc mais en tout cas rien ne remplace
l'ouverture intellectuelle et politique
et c'est vrai que on voit quand même je
pense que sur la revue on va dire que
son contenu n'est pas mauvais
mais d'abord c'est une
je vais pas dire une bouillie indigeste
mais c'est ça manque de plumes
lisibilité et puis il y a tellement de
choses qu'on sait plus trop ce qui
surnage bon il y a des choses
intéressantes dedans je vais donc je
fais une réponse simple il faut pas
forcément un nouveau livre blanc mais il
faut maintenir ses exercices
confidentiels parce que ça doit beaucoup
de choses doivent se traiter de manière
en privé sans ça pas forcément être
public
cette fertilisation croisée dans la
préparation des LPM ou des politiques de
sécurité défense la contribution des
parlementaires et des signes tanks et
d'autres personnalités me semblent tout
à fait féconde sur la Pologne la Pologne
sera ce qui était l'Allemagne dans les
années 60 et 70 c'est elle qui est en
première ligne ça sera potentiellement
une grande puissance militaire
européenne en 2030 et je crois qu'il
faut s'en féliciter
de la dire que le centre de gravité de
l'Europe se déplace vers l'Est il y a
énormément de chemin je pense qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui un peu trop
facilement cette expression dans les
débats dans les débats européens bon les
réalités économiques sont sont tout de
même ce qu'elles sont monsieur vallée
sur le
vous opposez moi je pose les faits au
récit le récit vous avez raison il a il
était là mais les fait c'est quoi c'est
que la présence militaire américaine en
Europe a augmenté dans les dernières
années d'Obama et à continuer
d'augmenter sous Trump et à augmenter
encore plus en tout pas forcément de
manière permanente mais depuis le début
de la guerre du frêne donc vous avez
raison le récit est ancien mais les
faits pour l'instant sont ceux qui sont
pour l'instant tenir la Méditerranée je
crois
je passe devant tenir la Méditerranée en
tout cas nous n'avons pas l'ambition de
tenir le Pacifique je crois dans le
Pacifique il y a deux choses la défense
de la souveraineté et des ressources de
notre drum
des populations bien sûr mais quand je
dis à souveraineté c'est d'abord
population et territoires mais aussi
ressources et défend la liberté de
navigation haute mer c'est ça nos
premiers intérêts donc je pense que pas
sûr que la comparaison Méditerranée
Pacifique soit finalement très très
féconde sur la question de la
simultanéité bien sûr et nous entrons là
peut-être je corrige très légèrement le
recul que je vais souhaiter prendre en
début d'intervention je crois que la
probabilité de simultanéité de scénario
grave impliquant directement ou
indirectement les Européens et
probablement plus grande aujourd'hui
qu'elle l'était il y a une dizaine
d'années je dirais les choses comme cela
sur les alors merci de nous donner
l'occasion de prêcher pour notre
paroisse
je veux pas dire qu'on est que nous
sommes réduits aux acquets mais je
rappellerai tout de même puisque vous
m'en donnez l'occasion que c'est vrai
les signes tank les signes tanks
français ont un en termes d'influence
même si notre travail n'est pas de
répercuter nécessairement la politique
et les positions françaises mais nous le
faisons aussi ne serait-ce qu'à tigre
d'explication nous avons je suis certain
que Thomas ne me démentira pas notre
rapport co-efficacité est exceptionnel
tout le monde le sait et malgré les
soutiens réels dont nous bénéficions
dans les administrations et l'attention
parfois porter à notre sort dans le
parfois jusqu'au plus haut de se faire
de l'État c'est vrai que la France du
point de vue des signes tank ne se donne
pas les moyens de ses ambitions alors
même que je le redis puisque Daniel
occasion nous ne coûtons vraiment pas
cher alors
oui mais non mais c'est pour ça que je
redis d'adéquation d'ambition et des
moyens nous nous lamentons du fait que
nous perdons en influence ici et là nous
le lamentons du fait nous regrettons que
nous ne voyons pas suffisamment tôt
suffisamment bien tel ou tel ou telle
perception se développer telle ou telle
un campagne de désinformation se
développer là encore justement c'est
aussi pour cela que nous pouvons aider
et si la fonction influence se développe
c'est bien qu'il y a une raison et la
fonction influence nous pouvons y
contribuer même si encore une fois ce
n'est pas notre travail de d'être les
porte-parole de de l'exécutif ou du
législatif ils font ça très bien un mot
très rapide sur la guerre
informationnelle vous avez parlé de la
Coupe du Monde moi je pense aux JO 2024
ça vient naturellement dans le débat il
faut se préparer à la possibilité que ce
soit effectivement pour la France un
moment compliqué de ce point de vue
enfin sur le défaut sur le 2% madame
je dirais que pour être très rapide
premièrement un rapport au PIB ne veut
rien dire puisque le PIB bouge alors
aujourd'hui on dit
on nous ne dépensons que 2% du PI mais
c'est parce que le pips est
considérablement développé depuis des
années 50 c'est une évidence alors quand
le covid est arrivé quand il y a des
crises le covid une crise financière ah
subitement on voit des pays qui arrivent
2% bah oui mais c'est parce que le PIB
c'est rétracté donc c'est quand même à
mon sens
quelque chose qui nous aurait nous
interpeller vous avez raison c'est vrai
que la le signal politique c'est un
label politique vous êtes des politiques
vous savez que quand c'est clair et
compréhensible les gens réagissent c'est
comme donner un âge pour la retraite par
exemple quand vous donnez un chiffre bah
oui ça mobilise qu'il soit clair que ça
n'apporte aucun avis positif ou négatif
de ma part sur sur cette question non
beaucoup plus pertinent sont la part des
dépenses d'équipement versus dépense de
personnel sans doute aussi la part des
dépenses de l'État mais là on entre dans
des sujets de comparaison internationale
extrêmement complexes et bien sûr les
critères qualitatifs comme le
pourcentage de telle ou telle capacité
opérationnelle de disponibilité la
disponibilité opérationnelle voilà les
critères beaucoup plus intéressants
merci monsieur le Président bon sur la
question madame la ministre
nouveau livre blood c'est là je
j'ajouterai à ce que Bruno a
répondu votre question sur le rarement
polonais peut-être un point moi quand
j'échange avec les collègues polonais me
disent deux choses à mon avis qui
doivent nous
nous interpeller la première c'est
qu'ils ont très bien compris notre très
grande difficulté à produire en Europe
donc quand il se tourne vers la Corée du
Sud c'est parce qu'ils comprennent aussi
la très grande difficulté aux États-Unis
à produire les cadences dont tout le
monde aura besoin donc ça c'est c'est à
mon avis un sujet tout à fait tout à
fait décisif puis un deuxième point qui
est
des échanges en marge de la conférence
de Munich il y a pas de limite désormais
pour eux en termes de réarmement
ce qui est une grande différence avec
nous ce qui pose un problème d'ailleurs
c'est à dire comment
on retient ou comment on comprend les
actions prises par certains de nos
alliés si il prenait par eux-mêmes des
décisions parce que je pense qu'on est
dans un moment où des pays comme la
Pologne
considèrent que c'est
le contexte historique idéal pour enfin
avoir une politique étrangère et une
politique de défense autonome et
d'imprimer une marque à l'Union
européenne une génération après leur
entrée à la fois dans l'Union européenne
et dans l'OTAN donc il considère qu'ils
ont une dynamique historique qui est de
leur côté et ça renvoie ce que j'essaie
d'indiquer dans mon exposé sur la
perception qu'ils peuvent avoir de la
relation franco-allemande
votre question sur est-ce que c'est pas
la est-ce que le rapport en fait Chine
Russie ça je pense que c'est
effectivement le grand sujet en réalité
est le plus un des plus difficiles
c'est-à-dire comment on apprécie cette
convergence
si une rue je l'ai dit et en particulier
l'intégration de la Russie au système
énergétique chinois parce qu'en fait la
principale conséquence de cette guerre
du crâne c'est le découplage énergétique
entre la Russie et l'Union européenne
avec des effets au fond de constitution
de blocs énergétiques et un enjeu de la
sécurité énergétique qui redevient un
sujet otanien quand on regarde où c'est
fait la compensation du gaz et du
pétrole russe en ce qui concerne le gaz
elle s'est un petit peu fait au Qatar et
en Algérie mais surtout
en Norvège au Royaume-Uni qui sont deux
pays qui ont des ressources déclinantes
comme chacun sait et avec le GNL
américain et donc l'inverse ça a été
évidemment la volonté chinoise de
davantage bénéficier des
approvisionnements gaziers et pétrolier
russe et iranien dans un contexte de
hausse de la demande chinoise
ce qui me frappe point c'est l'analyse
que nous avons fait de la de la Chine et
de la Russie je rappelle que l'URSS et
la Chine ont la même taille économique
en 1991 que la Russie aujourd'hui c'est
un dixième de l'économie chinoise et
donc avec un effectivement un phénomène
d'absorption ce qui est très intéressant
ce sont aussi les racines idéologiques
qui
unissent aujourd'hui cette amitié sans
limite entre la Chine et la Russie dont
je ne vois pas tellement un discours
d'ennemis au contraire je vois plutôt un
discours de très fort rapprochement et
le pays qui a le moins changé de
logiquement entre la guerre froide et la
période que nous connaissons c'est
précisément la Chine c'est à dire que on
l'a vu le 20e congrès du Parti
communiste chinois et tout sauf le
pendant du 20e congrès du Parti
communiste de l'Union soviétique c'est
pas la déstabilisation mais c'est la
réaffirmation du marxisme lénisme dans
sa pure eau
le la question de Monsieur
valini sur je pense c'est une excellente
question sur le ramement allemand en
fait
je ne serai pas l'expliquer comme un
historien j'ai pas tellement travaillé
sur ce sujet mais juste quelques
remarques qui là aussi peuvent être
utiles par rapport à la situation
actuelle
l'Allemagne sort de la Première Guerre
mondiale sans un carreau cassé sur son
territoire
donc sa base industrielle n'est pas
détruite
j'observe que c'est la même situation
pour la Russie qui n'a pas un carreau
cassé sur son territoire mais c'est
toute la base industrielle évidemment de
l'Ukraine qui est détruite qui
corroborent le point de fait par
Bruno pardon dans son exposé sur la
persistance au fond de la menace russe à
terme même s'il y avait un arrêt des
combats par ailleurs il y a une
coopération aussi
Germano soviétique extrêmement
importante dans ce dans ce dans ce
domaine une base industrielle
une volonté politique de le faire et de
l'imposer on va parfaire l'histoire du
nazisme mais ce sont effectivement à mon
avis
des éléments à garder à l'esprit et leur
tendance c'est-à-dire la décision prise
de notre côté de réarmer et
ce que nous avons réussi à faire en
termes de réarmement mais la très grande
difficulté à le traduire en site je
dirais de manière intellectuelle enfin
de là aussi refaire la question de la
drôle de guerre de ses conséquences
votre question sur au fond le l'endroit
où la France pourrait avoir un effet
majeur je vous rejoins assez volontiers
sur
ce que vous dites sur l'Indopacifique
quand on est plus capable de tenir
la Méditerranée au fond ce que nous
reproches fondamentalement les
États-Unis c'était une liste au fond
vous faites sortir d'Afrique
vous êtes peut-être encore très présent
en Méditerranée
occidentale et centrale moi en
Méditerranée orientale et donc
convaincre sur indépendamment de la
pertinence intellectuelle de toutes ces
discours sur l'Indo Pacifique qu'on
vaincre de notre capacité à modifier
l'environnement sans géopathique du
terme
et peu et peut recevoir leurs yeux donc
moi de mon point de vue l'endroit où
l'effet pour être produit c'est
précisément la Méditerranée je pense que
c'est le grand sujet sur lequel il faut
se
repencher mais dans tout dans les sur
les trois
occidentales centrales et orientale
la question de sénateur gatelin merci
beaucoup de de la poser là aussi on va
pas faire notre propre
promotion juste un chiffre j'ai pas pour
la frs peut-être que Bruno tu pourrais
ajouter mais l'Ifrit c'est un budget
annuel de 7 millions d'euros 56 salariés
donc en réalité nous avons décroché
collectivement par rapport aux autres
fines tank même pas américains en fait
européen nous avons décroché
donc effectivement il y a une question
ensuite qui est
le soutien qui est apporté à notre
activité je suis pas du tout en train de
faire de la une démarche mais c'est
effectivement une question assez
fondamentale parce que qui tient les
films tant que tient le récit et ce
récit est en train de changer de main
c'est aussi simple que ça et ça renvoie
votre question sur ensuite
l'empreinte que l'on peut avoir sur
sur les réseaux sociaux et au-delà moi
j'observe néanmoins je l'ai formulé dans
dans d'autres cadres une tendance
effectivement à voir les centres de
recherche comme des vecteurs d'influence
dans le cadre de la RNS et de la sixième
point stratégique bon personnel j'ai
choisi de travailler avec Ali free parce
qu'il y avait un f cela étant comme
Bruno l'a rappelé c'est pas notre
travail
et je suis très attentif à ce déport
parce que je pense que notre travail
concerne la première fonction
stratégique qui est
connaissance compréhension et
anticipation et effectivement là je vous
rejoindrai très aussi Monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur
j'observe une forme il y a de l'intérêt
mais il y a aussi une très grande
difficulté à prendre en compte nos
travaux lorsqu'ils peuvent être un peu
dissonnants ou lorsqu'il faut les rendre
audibles ça c'est notre savoir-faire
mais au fond je pense pas que nous
soyons beaucoup trompé
sur la Russie par exemple depuis
2014 ou depuis 2008 voilà mais les cours
rencontrés par ces travaux n'a pas été
celui que
j'espérais ce que vous dites sur
l'encerclement par la Russie si on peut
même partir plus loin en fait vous avez
une boucle pour beaucoup travailler sur
ces questions de l'article jusque
à l'Afrique du Nord et désormais le sel
et l'Afrique noire ce qui est quand même
très intéressant à noter c'est l'effet
produit par rapport au moyen mobilisé et
ce qui doit nous nous renvoyer à nos peu
de moyens consacrés intellectuellement
là aussi et puis en termes de moyens
plus tangible aux stratégies indirectes
au fond l'enseignement de la réussite
alors moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que
le règne de Vladimir Poutine a commencé
par un naufrage et finira par un
désastre mais les effets produits et les
effets leviers en particulier sur les
zones nous concernant sont d'une
redoutable efficacité par rapport au
moyen mobilisés
la question monsieur sénateur sur sur la
résidence cyber et l'aspect offensive
très franchement je suis pas compétent
sur le l'équilibre à trouver je vous
rejoins en revanche évidemment pour dire
que c'est centrales et que je
soutiens évidemment tous les efforts en
matière de cyber la prise en compte
comme comme espace commun je parle
davantage moi de guerre cognitive que de
guerre informationnel parce que on le
voit notamment sur un certain nombre
d'applications je pense à notre jeunesse
et TikTok des choses tout à fait
préoccupantes à observer sur la sur la
manière au fond dont nos cerveaux sont
en train d'être orienté
parce que cette mise en données du monde
est en train de régir à la fois nos
comportements et de consommateurs et nos
comportements politiques et ça c'est
très ciblé c'est très compris
effectivement par un certain nombre de
nos de nos adversaires la guerre
cognitive renvoie à cette notion
soviétique jadis
de mesures actives et je vous invite par
exemple à observer ça ça pourrait être
un travail que nous pourrions faire
d'ailleurs les liens qui peuvent exister
entre les prises de parole de diplomates
russes sur les chaînes d'information
continue par rapport à une situation sur
le terrain il y a une corrélation qui me
semble dans un certain temps de cas
évidente j'observe par ailleurs que les
diplomates européens n'ont pas le loisir
de s'exprimer sur les chaînes
d'information russe
sur votre question sur les réseaux les
réseaux sociaux nous avions essayé de
participer à l'initiative stop
djihadisme en fait c'est très difficile
et je ne suis pas du tout certain que ce
soit une démarche Top Down comme on
dirait qu'il soit la plus pertinente ce
que je retiens de la lecture même si ça
doit être encouragé en termes de
mobilisation moyen ça doit pas être
doute mais je remarque une des idées
intéressante du rapport gassilou sur la
résilience c'était un peu d'inversé
l'approche enfin un peu d'inverser
l'approche et de dire que ces questions
là doivent se poser au niveau des
citoyens comme une action citoyenne et
je le rejoindrai assez volontiers sur ce
point
bien merci beaucoup on va entamer la
deuxième série de questions mes chers
collègues est-ce que je peux vous
demander l'application de la
jurisprudence du président Cambon une
minute une question pour qu'on ait le
temps de d'écouter les les réponses de
nos invités la parole est à Jacques le
nez
merci président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur tertrey dans une note de
janvier dernier intitulé la cohérence
sans l'abondance point d'interrogation
la nouvelle programmation militaire se
dessine vous louez le choix du
gouvernement d'avoir préféré la
cohérence et la réactivité au volume et
à l'endurance pensez-vous que cette
cohérence permettra à la France de
rester fiable et crédit aux yeux de pays
avec des appareils de Défense au choix
stratégique différents et pour finir
quel regard portez-vous sur les liens
existants entre vos centres de recherche
et les travaux de notre commission
merci Jacques huxory
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur de literie je crois que c'est
vous qui tout à l'heure parliez de
réarmement moral et de notions
d'endurance et à l'instant de guerre
cognitive dans son discours aux armées
le 13 juillet dernier le président de la
République annoncé le doublement de la
réserve opérationnelle et on voit au
film notamment des auditions que en
Ukraine on voit toute l'importance de la
résistance de la de la population dans
la défense du pays que pensez-vous de
cette annonce et il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui
on voit dans des domaines différents la
crise sanitaire le climat qu'il est
difficile de mobiliser les esprits sans
dramatiser voire hystériser le débat
alors concrètement comment on serait à
un moment moral peut-il se matérialiser
je vous remercie merci Yannick
beaugrenard oui merci président
tout d'abord remerciement vraiment
appuyé à ces deux interventions je
trouve parfois que ça a beaucoup plus
d'intérêt que les auditions souvent
institutionnelles et que ça amène à
beaucoup plus de réflexion et
d'informations donc merci beaucoup je
veux revenir sur les
modifications du comportement américain
sous les trois
présidents américaines dernières
peut-on faire confiance aujourd'hui dans
le fait que les Américains interviennent
manifestement de manière importante en
Ukraine et je mets cela en opposition
avec la non-intervention de l'Amérique
sous la présidence d'Obama au moment où
à ça en Syrie avait utilisé les armes
chimiques et donc contrairement aux
engagements américains qui avaient été
pris et du coup les Français se sont
trouvés la France est trouvée
particulièrement isolés à ce moment là
est-ce que ce
non respect de l'engagement américain
n'a-t-il pas entraîné de la part de
Poutine et de la Russie la possibilité
du coup d'intervenir comme ils l'ont
déjà fait avant en Crimée et en Ukraine
ensuite et selon vous cette nouvelle
confiance éventuelle envers les
États-Unis d'Amérique qui leur
intervention potentielle sur le
territoire européen était le durable ou
pas par rapport également et compte tenu
plutôt de la fragilité
constatée aujourd'hui de la démocratie
de la démocratie en Amérique j'ai une
deuxième question mais c'est une phrase
monsieur le Président sur l'accord de
défense si vous avez insisté sur la
carte de défense avec avec la Grèce
pensez-vous que nous avons les moyens
militaires de notre ambition
diplomatique merci
merci Jean-Marc todeschkini
merci le président à mon tour bon merci
pour vos analyses qui sont toujours très
intéressantes on changerait un peu de
zone
j'aimerais que nous teniez votre analyse
sur
ce qui est nous est arrivé ce qui arrive
à la France face à la Russie mais
surtout avec Wagner au Mali au Burkina
peut-être demain au Tchad je sais pas
quelle analyse vous faites
le voyage du président de la République
en Afrique après son discours à l'Élysée
née apparemment pas un succès pour les
populations
qu'a-t-on raté en tout cas dans nos
analyses dans les analyses pour en
arriver là pour se faire finalement
chasser de certains pays et est-ce à
votre avis cela a une incidence sur les
analyses que peuvent faire nos états
major et nos militaires
merci
merci Jean-Marc bruno Sido merci
monsieur le Président le président de la
République
dit plusieurs fois qu'il avait
l'ambition d'avoir une armée au format
complet
selon vous elle se souhaitable possible
ou est-ce que ça nous amène pas avoir
une armée échantillonnaire merci
et Bruno Ludovic
merci monsieur le Président merci à vous
deux messieurs pour vos interventions
respectives extrêmement intéressantes
c'en est presque frustrant de ne pouvoir
en parler que 1h30 tant les sujets étant
ce recul sur sur le regard mondial et
essentiel avant de pouvoir engager des
actions aujourd'hui avoir une une
explication sur ce sur cette sur ces
relations mondiales vous l'avez abordé
par certains points sur un regard
historique et je sais aussi que c'est
une de vos spécialités notamment avec
les dessins Neo impériaux de Poutine
j'en ai une vision un peu plus directe
un peu moins poétique parfois sur
simplement des visions intéressées
notamment ce qui concerne les politiques
énergétiques et aujourd'hui avoir une
LPM à la hauteur de ses ambitions c'est
évidemment être en mesure de mettre en
exergue sa crédibilité technologique et
financière au regard de la communauté
internationale c'est être en capacité de
défendre sa nation bien évidemment mais
c'est aussi pour moi et pour de nombreux
pays où la zone de conflit n'est pas
clairement identifiée on n'a pas
toujours des zones de conflits bien
claires être en mesure d'accompagner des
ambitions énergétiques très fortes de
ces pays-là et aujourd'hui c'est une
sorte de d'aide militaire généreuse ou
une aide intéressée je dirais
comment quel est votre avis sur cette
question là s'il vous plaît je peux
donner un exemple par exemple sur
dans en mer de Chine voilà on a une aide
américaine militaire qui risque de se
mettre en place si demain Taïwan était
attaqué parce que il y a des
semi-conducteurs je pense aussi voilà à
toutes ces tout ce qui tient c'est ces
points énergétiques avec une aide
militaire derrière qui est un petit peu
promise tout du moins sous-jacente et
pas toujours avoué merci
une question messieurs à vous poser sur
la dissuasion dissuasion nucléaire qui
est une question que l'on aborde peu en
général dans les discussions budgétaires
alors même que l'effort financiers de la
nation à sa faveur est constant et
relativement important elle représente
chaque année au moins 20% du total des
crédits d'études amont j'ai relevé que
dans son discours de Mont-de-Marsan sur
LPM le président de la République avait
particulièrement insisté et je cite sur
les efforts considérables que nous lui
consacrons mais aussi et c'est en fait
le point sur lequel je souhaiterais vous
faire réagir l'adaptation de cette
dissuasion aux exigences contemporaines
sont renforcement pour assurer sa
robustesse et sa fiabilité ainsi que la
nécessité de mieux la faire comprendre à
ce qu'elle interroge alors au cercle
restreint désespères de la dissuasion
que vous êtes que vous suggère se
positionnement présidentiel de la
dissuasion faut-il y voir une évolution
possible de la doctrine de la
communication pourquoi et contre ces
menaces nouvelles voilà la liste des
questions est close et je vous laisse le
temps de la réponse à chacun d'entre
vous merci
merci beaucoup donc je vais essayer de
là aussi de faire de de suivre la règle
du présent quand
votre question le successeur sur le lien
avec les centres de recherche juste un
chiffre un Liffré à la dernière plus de
30 auditions parlementaires c'est très
nouveau en moyenne c'était plutôt
disparu donc il y a on sent une demande
à laquelle évidemment on est très
heureux de
répondre
j'encourage les chercheurs aussi à lire
la production du Sénat ou de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
très bons rapports je trouve qu'ils sont
faits par les par les parlements donc ça
peut être tout à fait tout à fait croisé
donc voilà c'est le lien on peut on
pourrait faire plus après c'est aussi là
aussi on revient sur la question moyen
on pourrait évidemment faire beaucoup
plus c'est une manière peut-être de
compléter la réponse où je n'ai pas fait
tout à l'heure sur le nouveau livre
blanc ou pas je pense qu'on manque d'un
dispositif permanent pour faire cette
analyse stratégie continue et c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose de très sorcier
à mon avis a inventé en fait et à mettre
en oeuvre et on pourrait tout à fait
imaginer un instrument associant des
centres de recherche et des
parlementaires permanents et qui tourne
et qui fasse des points strat de manière
de manière continue et pas
en fonction de la production d'un livre
blanc ou d'un document stratégique
votre question sur le sénateur sur le
sur le réarmement moral et forcément
c'est comme ça qu'on peut la résumer
d'abord peut-être là aussi un rappel
chronologique qui m'a qui m'a frappé en
préparant cette audition
1996 des signaux présents Chirac de
suspendre la conscription
dont on mesure en fait toutes les
implications sociétales d'une génération
après non pas que je sois nostalgique de
la conception je suis de 99 12 donc j'ai
aussi un regard assez critique sur ce
qui était devenu la conscription et
notamment pour ceux qui échappaient
mais ce rappel est important parce que
je pense qu'il est il est aussi décisif
dans un certain différent enfin dans un
certain désaccord franco-allemand qui
s'est installé à ce moment-là
2007 la RGPP décider par présent Sarkozy
dont on l'a aussi nous voyons les effets
pas simplement dans le domaine qui est
notre aujourd'hui dans le domaine
énergétique notamment et 2017
l'arbus stratégique et la décision
d'arrêter cette diminution cette érosion
constante des crédits de défense
l'aspect l'aspect force morale le chef
d'état-major des armées et insiste
effectivement dans
la plupart de ces interventions puisque
en ce qui me concerne la surprise
stratégique de l'année dernière n'a pas
été l'agression russe mais la résistance
ukrainienne et son niveau de résistance
à la fois en termes opérationnel et en
termes aussi de de mobilisation comment
y parvenir ça serait une peut-être une
autre audition je ne pense pas que le
SNU soit la réponse c'est-à-dire que je
vois le SNU ce profilé comme 15 jours
qui serait censé
réparé plusieurs années de non
instruction de non-éducation donc ça là
aussi peut-être le mérite d'exister
c'est à dire de comme révélateur d'une
prise de conscience mais l'adaptation de
l'outil à mon avis mérite là aussi de
des débats très sérieux et très
documentés
la
question sur l'analyse de Wagner
et
aux Français oui moi aussi je vous
rejoins c'est à dire que c'est ce que je
dis dans mon intervention je pense que
il faut faire un texte comme disent les
militaires très précis de ce qui s'est
passé et le regarder très froidement
comment se fait-il qu'en fait une
société militaire privée arrive à
produire un tel effet
ensuite sur la nature de la de la
présence en Afrique de choses il y a ce
débat sur le maintien d'une présence
d'une présence militaire c'est-à-dire
que le reproche et qu'il faut entendre
qui est fait c'est que la présence
militaire française d'ailleurs qui se
fait dans des zones qui sont les moins
importantes pour notre commerce
extérieur en termes de pourcentage je le
je le souligne aussi a été vu par les
élites locales ou par les populations
locales comme trop militariser c'est à
dire que la présence de l'uniforme du
regalien extérieur
probablement été trop devenu trop
visible c'est c'est un élément à mon
avis à apprendre en compte et le
deuxième élément c'est que moi je suis
assez perplexe sur l'idée de vouloir
faire de l'influence sans présence
et donc je pense que le débat sur la
présence en Afrique mérite probablement
nécessaire de l'adapter compte tenu de
cette évolution des sociétés africaines
et de cette impression de rejet que vous
évoquiez que je partage
mais là aussi je pense qu'il faut pas
forcément
se précis se précipiter et peut-être
essayer de réfléchir à d'autres
modalités présentes c'est aussi comme ça
que j'ai lu les dernières interventions
présidentielles
votre question monsieur le sénateur sur
modèle complet est-ce que ça est
synonyme d'un d'une armée
chantillonnaire évidemment oui et on le
voit bien sur tout le débat que nous
avons eu sur les munitions les Free a
produit une note qui a rencontré un
certain échos sur les stocks
de mes jeunes collègues qu'il a qui l'a
rédigé
oui le choix le choix le choix complet
c'est le choix échantillonnaire il
s'explique par les ambitions il
s'explique aussi par la nécessité de
maintenir à flot la BITD l'alternative
ce serait quoi en fait est-ce que il y a
eu un c'est des barres reviennent de
temps en temps il y a eu le je dirais le
mythe de la de la revue de la stratégie
intégrité britannique qui est capable de
se de se grouper un bras et de se couper
son armée de terre en fait d'ailleurs ce
qui explique pourquoi elle soutient en
matériel elle a pu soutenir si
rapidement les Ukrainiens
à titre personnel je ne pense pas que ce
soit la la bonne direction je pense que
la bonne direction c'est la cohérence
puisque le complet et surtout d'essayer
de gagner un peu en profondeur
votre question alors tout à fait
décisive sur l'aspect politique
énergétique où effectivement moi je
considère que si on nous faisions un
effort de grande stratégie
la première pierre c'est la question
énergiquement c'est aussi simple que ça
parce que quand on regarde ce que font
nos adversaires et nos compétiteurs en
réalité
pour les pays que j'ai étudié récemment
c'est tout à fait au coeur de leur de
leur démarche au fond il y a deux
questions et qu'on pourrait aussi
reprendre ultérieurement la première si
vous laissez qu'on pourrait résumer
l'attitude des pays membres en
permanents du Conseil de sécurité depuis
45 vis-à-vis du Moyen-Orient comme
je prends je prends l'énergie et je
vends des armes
et ça c'est une c'est extrêmement
structurant en terme d'économie
politique internationale en particulier
pour nos propres systèmes et l'exception
de la Russie qui n'a pas besoin de
prendre de l'énergie mais qui vend des
armes
et la deuxième question là aussi plus
prospective c'est on a une puissance un
passage de la puissance entre la
puissance britannique et américaine 19e
20e siècle il s'est fait avec le pétrole
c'est-à-dire que la puissance américaine
repose sur le fossile je rappelle que le
fossile
représente encore 85 % du mix mondial
c'était la même proportion des bus des
années 90 donc l'aspect fossile reste
absolument
central en termes stratégique
et la question c'est au fond qu'est-ce
que serait une puissance des carbonée ça
c'est l'ambition chinoise mais cette
ambition à mon avis même un horizon 2050
elle ne peut pas faire l'économie d'une
réflexion très sérieuse sur le fossile
c'est-à-dire que même si on la baisse
même si on arrivait à baisser le mix
soyons très ambitieux à 65%, il
resterait 65 % de fossiles et ce serait
c'est évidemment très ambitieux sur la
dissuasion nucléaire je laisserai Bruno
répondre parce que là aussi je suis pas
forcément compétent il y a une notion
qui avait été évacuée lors des débats
de 2017 c'est la notion de dissuasion
conventionnelle
et je la trouve intéressante parce que
je crois qu'une partie de la situation
en Ukraine s'explique par le fait que
les Européens en termes conventionnel
n'ont pas été pris au sérieux par les
Russes
je vais être rapide monsieur le
Président puisque je sais que vous avez
une autre réunion
quand j'ai globalement tu as prouvé les
grandes lignes telles que présentées par
le Président de la République du futur
loi de futur projet de loi de
programmation militaire je m'empresse de
d'ajouter que le diable pourrait être
dans les détails et que donc on peut se
féliciter les grandes orientations mais
ça ne vaut pas approfation auparavant de
ce que sera le projet de loi sur la
perception par nos alliés de ce que nous
faisons la dépense c'est bien mais la
présence est encore mieux
malheureusement
et en dépit de tout ce que j'ai dit sur
la diversité des moyens qui nous
permettent de nous présenter comme allié
exemplaire le ce qu'on appelle aux
États-Unis le bin cantine le comptage de
haricots
il voyait aucune aucun mépris vient le
contraire pour nos militaires c'est à
dire combien de forces et combien
d'hommes et de femmes à tel moment
projet à l'Est combien d'avions etc ça
reste tout à fait central dans la
perception de de nos partenaires sur
très brièvement je partage totalement ce
qu'elle dit Thomas sur nos relations en
tant que tu recherches vis-à-vis de vos
commissions les auditions vous nous
faites l'honneur et l'amitié de nous de
nous solliciter fréquemment nous sommes
à votre disposition de ce point de vue
je le rappelle vos rapports sont
précieux je confirme et j'ajoute que
c'est pas seulement nous sommes des des
directeurs d'instituts mais nos experts
sont aussi à votre disposition y compris
à titre personnel la consultation d'un
expert de la de la frs je vais pas
m'engager pour les free la consultation
informelle sur un sujet précis elle est
elle est gracieuse voilà tout simplement
nous sommes tous des républicains nous
nous sommes là aussi pour vous aider on
peut pas vous écrire un rapport de 100
pages gratuitement ça non mais n'hésitez
pas à nous contacter directement
franchement voilà et voilà nous nous
sommes la visibilité aujourd'hui de de
Nothing tank mais nous avons des
richesses insoupçonnées parfois en notre
simple 2013 c'est Suez à l'envers ça a
été un choc pour la France président
François Hollande en reparle encore
régulièrement est-ce que ça a été un
encouragement à la Russie je me méfie
énormément cet argument je dirais que
c'est cumulatif l'idée d'une faiblesse
ou d'un manque de résolution occidentale
ça vient de l'accumulation de non
décision de cuisiner d'hésitation de
retraite etc je pense intuitivement je
pense parce que ça ne peut pas être
prouvé bien sûr je dirais que c'est
plutôt cumulatif comment est-ce que le
récit français peut être audible
je crois que nous ne gagnons pas à
répéter sans arrêt que le retrait
américain était inévitable encore une
fois parce que ça fait 70 ans qu'on le
dit peut-être qu'il l'est je ne suis pas
sûr que nous convaincrons nos
partenaires de l'urgence de l'Europe de
la défense en répétant encore une fois
qu'il est inévitable sur la Grèce qu'on
a les moyens alors je rappelle d'abord
que la Grèce a d'abord besoin d'être
rassuré de savoir qu'elle n'est pas
toute seule et donc il y a d'abord ça
l'aspect politique et psychologique un
accord de défense c'est aussi c'est
aussi cela je pense que enfin je crois
savoir que l'état-major les armées
assure prendre en compte cette nouvelle
réalité politique ou juridique et c'est
vrai que à mon sens elle a raison de
penser à la possibilité d'une crise
majeure dans laquelle nous serions
impliqués y compris pourquoi pas par des
combats de haute intensité dans dans
cette région je n'en sais pas plus et
donc cette a fortiori je n'en dirais pas
plus mais je n'en sais en plus Wagner ça
mériterait une audition soit je vais me
permettre de ne pas le mentionner le
format complet je partage quasi Thomas
l'échantillonnage et le bonsaï ont leur
vertu l'important c'est la cohérence la
capacité de remonter en puissance et
l'abandon et l'alternative surtout je
suis d'accord avec moi l'abandon de
capacité se couper une main ou un bras
un pied bah ça repousse pas voilà ça
repousse ça repousse très difficilement
les Britanniques l'ont appris à leurs
dépens sur Taïwan attention Taïwan n'a
jamais été un enjeu énergétique et n'est
devenu un enjeu majeur sur le plan
économique et technologique que très
récemment TSMC c'était un nain il y a
quelques années et d'ailleurs bon il y a
toutes le débat sur quelle capacité TSMC
peut-être peut transférer sur le
territoire américain est-ce que c'est
pas une police d'assurance pour eux
d'avoir la capacité de fabriquer les
semis conducteurs les plus les plus
petits etc bon voilà je dirais que cela
mais je pense que véritablement Taïwan
aujourd'hui c'est ça a toujours été ça
reste beaucoup plus un enjeu
réputationnel sur la capacité et la
volonté les États-Unis à maintenir leurs
engagement de défense en Asie Pacifique
c'est un enjeu stratégique aussi bien
sûr là encore une fois comme on dit
regarder la carte c'est tout cela c'est
défendre une démocratie chinoise c'est
tout cela avant d'être un éventuel
intérêt économique j'ajouterai
simplement que sur le plan sur le plan
de la stratégie énergie climat j'allais
dire que j'attendais ce que Thomas le
dise mais tu tu l'as dit je crois que de
manière implicite c'est pas seulement de
gros compétiteurs mais aussi nos plus
grands alliés pour lesquels le le
l'équation énergie climat est au centre
désormais de leur politique économique
et enfin cela dissuasion je crois que
l'adaptation c'est simplement c'est
d'abord et avant tout les défenses les
défenses antimissiles les défenses
entiers aériennes c'est aussi la
deuxième génération d'armes nucléaires
sans sans essai je ne crois pas et je ne
vois pas de raison personnellement qu'on
est un changement de doctrine à
l'horizon en tout cas personnellement je
ne vois pas forcément la nécessité nous
avons une doctrine assez souple à tout
point de vue en revanche je suis
toujours extrêmement perplexe et parfois
très critique sur cette idée de mieux
faire comprendre et de faire preuve de
pédagogie ce mot est terrible sur votre
pédagogie est terrible il est terrible
dans tous les domaines je me permette de
dire bref digression qu'il est aussi
terrible en politique intérieure voilà
je ferme je ferme la digression
nos concitoyens nos alliés nous sommes
pas dans une salle de classe ne
concitoyens nous alliés ne sont pas les
élèves et que je crois qu'il faut se
méfier terriblement de ce de cette
expression je m'arrêterai là monsieur le
président
merci à tous les deux pour
la richesse de vos présentations et le
temps que vous nous avez consacré ce
matin je crois qu'effectivement dans nos
travaux nous avons besoin des auditions
institutionnelles mais nous avons aussi
besoin de temps à autre de sortie des
sentiers battus et je crois que c'était
un petit peu la démarche de ce matin et
je voudrais remercier le président
Cambon et les services de la Commission
d'avoir organisé ce tour de table qui
j'en suis certain va contribuer à
alimenter la réflexion individuelle de
l'ensemble des collègues et par la même
la réflexion collective l'un de vous
deux a parlé de fertilisation croisée en
tout cas ce matin vous avez contribué à
la nôtre et vraiment au nom de
l'ensemble de la commission je vous en
remercie Merci à VOUS bonne journée
alors mes chers collègues ne quittez pas
puisque on a un autre point d'ordre du
jour qui arrive et je crois que le
président est arrivé donc je vais lui
céder la place